il faut expérimenter la vie voilà la
plupart du temps on nous le permet pas
parce qu'on a été dressé depuis tout
petit à façon nous dit c'est-à-dire pas
jouer avec son caca et tous ces trucs là
déjà ça commence mal à partir de ce
moment là
comment ça va super encore mort mais ça
va ouais toujours envie c'est déjà pas
mal
Guillaume du stand le père de La
Morandais Natasha St-Pier Emmanuel
Philibert de Savoie Carignan Laurent
Baffie voilà Guillaume du stand auteur
éditeur et vous publiez d'ailleurs chez
ballon dans la collection que vous
dirigez qui s'appelle le rayon un livre
qui s'appelle génie divin vous savez
comment on fait
je comprends pas que 10 Falco le fasse
et que vous ne fassiez pas
il faut savoir des plaire baladeur la
fée recar la fée je ne le fais pas
raison de plus Jean-Paul de la fée non
bien
sûr alors
commence très fort votre bouquin
Guillaume du stand vous parlez de
Renault Camus qui s'est écrivain qui
dans son journal intime publié chez
Gallimard l'année dernière se plaignait
qui est trop de Juifs dans une émission
qui s'appelle
panorama sur France Culture et vous page
12 du bouquin sur dès le début vous
dites attention je ne suis pas Renault
Camus je suis pire donc vous allez
direct hausse dans la provoque pourquoi
parce que d'abord moi je peux me le
permettre parce que je suis juif donc
c'est plus facile pour attaquer les
Juifs quand on est Juifs enfin en gros
on a le droit d'attaquer le Juif que
quand on est Juifs c'est clair c'est ça
et c'est vrai d'ailleurs page 100 de
votre bouquin vous donner votre cv
complet et effectivement vous donner
votre prénom William barranès expliqué
que vous êtes Juifs séfarade et ashkénaz
mélangé et donc le fait d'être juif vous
autorise à dire ce que vous dites page
26 et vous avez toute une litanie sur
qu'il meurt qu'il meurt qu'il meurt on
attend qu'il meurt on attend on attend
patiemment on attend que ça se passe le
fait des Juifs vous autorise à
surenchérir sur Renault Camus
lui il attaque les Juifs en disant ils
sont pas français ils ont pas de racines
et moi je dis les Juifs
en ce moment ont une espèce de magistère
moral sur la France et puis je pense
l'Occident général mais bon beaucoup la
France voilà ça restera à la France
parce qu'on leur demande de sauver le
judo christianisme si vous voulez dans
la mesure où christianisme s'est
discrédité c'est vrai que plus personne
à l'église à part les gens de plus de 60
ans c'est ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure vous disiez tout à l'heure
qu'avec des vieux frère
avec le père de la mort
je voudrais continuer parce que je
voudrais continuer à raconter mon truc
vous dites que les Juifs exercent
aujourd'hui en Occident à magistère
moral parce que on leur demande de
sauver le judéo christianisme parce que
le christianisme c'est
discrédités au sens où plus personne a
envie de faire ce que fait le pas pour
faire
c'est quand même curieux alors allez-y
allez-y alors non mais expliquez votre
thèse calmement
c'est pas vraiment une tête c'est un peu
sympa constat quoi je ne la pas
ce que je constate c'est que les gens
les plus intéressants dans dans
je vais être horrible mais qui ont moins
de 35 ans ils vont pas à l'église ils
vont pas au GMJ ils vont plutôt en rêve
et en boîte de nuit voilà
il y a pas les deux millions de gens
qui devraient prendre des extasies au
lieu de prendre des hosties
effectivement pourquoi devoir parce que
l'ecstasie c'est très très bien mais pas
de terrorisme là-dessus lécher la
liberté au jour bien j'en ai l'air
d'accord les jeunes derrière ils y
connaissent rien alors
je vous demande de vous arrêter bien on
continue
quand même se Baladur il a un magistère
moral alors lui pour le coup donc dans
ce CV qui est page son de votre bouquin
vous donnez votre date de naissance 1965
vous parlez de votre homosexualité vous
parlez des livres que vous avez écrit
mais alors pourquoi je comprends pas
avant qu'on vous raconteiez votre vie
quand vous donnez votre CV vous disiez
que vous avez fait les nazes ce qui est
pas mal et que après vous avez été juges
pourquoi dans ce CV là vous oubliez ça
vous le vous le rayez de votre vie cette
période Lena jugent administratifs
et je me suis dit bon je vais garder ça
pour la prochaine fois non parce que
vous avez fait le concours général si on
se pose l'ENA quand même c'est pas mal
vous avez été juges à Tahiti parce qu'à
l'époque j'ai découvert vous étiez
séropositif vous avez décidé de fuir
Paris et ça d'un seul coup c'est ça ne
fait plus partie de votre biographie
bien à part ça le CV quand même juste
sur un certain nombre de points vous
habitez le marais pourquoi vous pouvez
pas habiter dans hétérolande vous êtes
obligé d'habiter dans le dans le ghetto
c'est pas loin de mon travail à pied si
vous voulez ce qui est quand même déjà
un avantage et à part ça je trouve que
ouais quand on rentre dans le Marais on
voit des [__] moi je me dis voilà c'est
des gens qui vivent et ailleurs je sens
moins quoi
lesbiennes je pense que tout le monde
sait qu'il baisse beaucoup plus quoi
déjà et c'est quand même très important
dans la vie quoi le plaisir me semble
alors vous êtes donc vous dites que vous
êtes éditeur écrivain vous avez 18000
francs par mois et alors maintenant
venons-en au fond du bouquin vous dites
c'est votre thèse vous dites on se croit
libre c'est faux il y a toujours des
oppresseurs et des opprimés il y a
toujours des bourreaux et des victimes
le monde est toujours homophobe raciste
patriarcale sexiste autoritaire
familiariste théocratique classique etc
donc finalement pour vous quand on dit
68 a permis une certaine libéralisation
de la société etc pour vous c'est rien
n'a changé en fait
non non je pense qu'on a avancé mais je
pense qu'il y a eu un énorme retour en
arrière quoi et et on sait très bien il
y a des dates
moi je pense que la cassure elle s'est
passé en 1975 quand Giscard a remonté
les Champs-Élysées en pull je crois
qu'il a fait en pull pour montrer qu'il
était cool et en fait tout le long des
Champs-Élysées il y avait des films
porno c'est tout partout et donc toutes
les télés ont montré le défi du 14
juillet avec le président de la
République et suce moi prendre matheux
je suis mouillé pénétration pareil
maintenant c'est choquant
oui alors voilà et et bah ça a donné
lieu à une espèce de levée de bouclier
de Lord morale c'est-à-dire que bon je
sais pas quand le lendemain l'assemblée
la droite et la gauche puritaine de
l'époque ce sont alliés pour dire on
peut pas permettre aux Français d'être
libre qu'ils arrêtent ils vont tous voir
des films où il y a des actes sexuels
que l'Église chrétienne nous a dit qu'il
fallait pas faire donc on va mettre fin
à tout ça et on va voter une loi 75 pour
vous c'est la le retour en arrière c'est
le début de c'est le début de ce qu'on
est en train de voir finir maintenant
parce que je pense que là on va vers
autre chose non mais il a choisi un
créneau provoque je vais pas l'aider
quand même
j'ai rien à dire alors votre bouquin
vous faites état de vos combats
habituels
usage récréatif des drogues donc on y
arrive vous dites tant que la gauche ne
l'égalise pas la drogue toutes les
drogues il n'y a pas de gauche donc
c'est ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement de pin
je peux toujours attendre
usage récréatif des drogues dérèglement
des sens alors vous dites tout le monde
a envie de se faire attacher fister
godet fouetter partout et bouffer du
sperme mais les gens ne le font pas
parce qu'ils ont peur
ça c'est l'évidence mais c'est pas du
tout de c'est pas du tout de mais c'est
pas du tout de dérèglement des sens qui
s'agit c'est simplement de
d'expérimenter la vie c'est tout il faut
expérimenter la vie voilà la plupart du
temps nous le permet pas parce qu'on a
été dressé depuis tout petit à façon
qu'on nous dit c'est-à-dire pas jouer
avec son caca et tous ces trucs là déjà
ça commence mal à partir de ce moment là
quand on dit
je vais avoir la grippe pour vraiment
expérimenter la vie c'est ça que vous
faites mais une fois que vous l'avez
expérimenté vous continuez à le faire
vous aimez ça
justement
très content d'avoir fait donc là vous
avez tout fait là
attachéister godet fouetter partout
un moment c'est devenu un peu comme une
drogue non non mais dépendants d'une
sexualité non ça devient pas comme une
drogue c'était comme une drogue ouais
c'était comme une drogue et je m'en suis
libéré ça va mieux là
[Applaudissements]
bien tourné finalement ça lui demande et
beaucoup plus sinistre c'est vrai autre
combat de Guillaume du stand baiser sans
capote
ce qu'on appelle le verbe
vous êtes séropositif vous baisez entre
séropositif au moins quand même
j'aimerais bien mais personne veut
coucher avec moi parce que je suis trop
connu maintenant alors c'est très
embarrassant mais ouais
pourquoi parce que pourquoi parce que
c'est une façon attendez c'est
intéressant ça c'est une façon de punir
votre célébrité de dire il est tellement
connu ben rien que pour l'emmerder je
vais pas coucher avec lui c'est ça bah
ouais cette histoire de baiser sans
capote la Guillaume c'est quand même
important je veux dire vous êtes
d'accord avec Jean-Paul II vous me direz
d'une certaine façon mais sauf que vous
c'est quand même il y a il y a un
paradoxe
Cyril Collard quand même quelque part
c'est à dire c'est un revolver que vous
avez entre les jambes quand même non
que j'ai entre les jambes tout le monde
a revolver dans la tête franchement je
veux dire la vie c'est ça quoi c'est il
y a un risque de violence dans la vie
c'est vrai et moi ce que je demande
c'est simplement qu'on m'empêche pas
d'avoir une sexualité normale avec des
gens
qui ont le même statut c'est logique que
moi et vous dites d'ailleurs le coup de
génie divin ça reprend le type de votre
livre c'est d'avoir mis ce problème de
de baiser sans capote ce que vous
appelez le beerbach sur le plan
philosophique c'est-à-dire que
finalement c'est la responsabilité c'est
comme un c'est comme un c'est comme un
devoir du bac en philo quoi moi ce que
j'ai dit c'est que on est responsable
pour soi et pas pour les autres et ouais
c'est un point important parce que c'est
effectivement le contraire de ce que
plein de gens essaient de nous faire
croire et je pense que c'est très
dangereux de penser qu'on est
responsable pour les autres parce que à
partir du moment où on pense ça on
s'occupe plus de soi
et puis il se passe plus rien quoi
et pour les autres et pour les non on
n'est pas responsable non on peut les
écouter les autres on peut les écouter
c'est vraiment la seule chose qu'on peut
faire pas mal ah ben ouais c'est pas mal
je le fais beaucoup là on a un point
d'accord est-ce que alors pour être
beaucoup plus prosaïque est-ce que il y
a pas quand vous baisez sans capote avec
des séropositifs est-ce qu'il y a pas un
risque de surinfection ça c'est ce qu'on
nous raconte c'est toujours pas prouvé
et puis et puis même s'il y avait un
risque de surinfection
on a le droit de le prendre ce risque
alors quand vous dites Guillaume du
stand toute façon meurt pas du sida moi
je suis séropositif depuis 9 ans je suis
toujours là
j'ai rien pris jusqu'à récemment une
littérature et tout ça c'est dans la
tête vous avez quand même pas peur de
donner un exemple un peu négatif
je disais ça quand j'étais fou je disais
ça
quand je pensais non mais sérieusement
[Applaudissements]
voilà non je dis ça quand je pensais que
j'allais
passer parce que j'étais invincible un
gros délire quoi mais je pense que dans
des situations extrêmement violentes les
gens viennent fous quoi c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont fous dans la vie c'est
extrêmement ça va ouais ça va je prends
des médicaments je pense que je vais
mourir dans 10 ans c'est pas de très
agréable mais bon je vais travailler
beaucoup et puis comme ça ça se passera
correctement on aura inventé un remède
ouais ça m'aura pas empêché de stresser
bon alors vous êtes favorable à
l'euthanasie oui oui bien sûr évidemment
non je pense que c'est la moindre des
libertés que de choisir sa mort quoi la
position de l'Église sur l'euthanasie
c'est quoi c'est c'est de développer les
soins palliatifs pour éviter la
souffrance la souffrance n'est pas Réda
autrice et moi souffrir pour aller au
ciel déjà c'est sûr non on peut chauffer
si c'est un choix personnel et délicieux
j'ai pas pour le subir pour le subir et
moi j'étais très impressionné parce que
ma mère est morte il y a un an elle a eu
6 mois de juin palliatif et nous l'avons
accompagné frère et soeur chaque jour et
je trouve que ce sont des étapes
extraordinaires pour connaître la
personne jusqu'au bout alors là aussi
plus grave quand même Guillaume page 274
vous prenez le génisme vous dites pour
booster l'intelligence il faut éliminer
les gens quand un quotient intellectuel
inférieur à 180 sinon on restera
toujours des singes
non mais je dis pas qu'il faut les
éliminer maintenant ceux qui sont
d'accord ça me rassure parce que c'est
comme les fonctionnaires si vous voulez
plus engager
on attend qu'il partent à la retraite
quoi c'est ça c'est la même chose mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec ceux qui vont
naître et qui ont moins de 180 que sur
un téléphone c'est pareil on sera obligé
de les garder mais non mais là où c'est
un vrai débat c'est que c'est
l'intelligence ouais enfin si on peut il
faut mettre le paquet génétiquement pour
améliorer l'espèce humaine c'est vrai
qu'on est con parce que ça se voit les
gens sont manipulés les gens sont des
gogos les gens sont des victimes voilà
moi ça me fatigue on avance on avance
alors vous en prenez à tout le monde
dans ce bouquin et puis alors ce qui m'a
le plus surpris même au [__] vous dites
en fait
les gens veulent toujours passer pour le
[__] actif
comme celui qui se fait pas [__]
parce que finalement le fait de pas se
faire [__] d'être un [__] actif ça
rend un peu moins [__] donc c'est mieux
je sais pas l'injure de base c'est quoi
c'est quand même [__] non moi je suis
pour qu'on criminalise les agents
homophobes
tant mieux parce que moi j'en ai marre
de vivre dans un monde où j'entends [__]
[__] tout le temps quoi je me sens
visé ça m'énerve alors dites l'actif est
mis en valeur alors que le passif il est
considéré comme une [__] bah c'est
l'homme qui est mis en valeur et la
femme qui est considéré comme un comme
un tas de merde
ça veut dire qu'il y aura un machisme
homo finalement ce que je dis c'est que
les rapports de pouvoir dans
l'humanité changeront pas tant que les
hommes vivront pas leur homosexualité
naturelle et que donc ils se feront pas
[__] par d'autres messieurs comme
parce que ce jour-là il comprendront les
femmes il les mépriseront plus voilà
est un peu exhibitionniste quoi moi
c'est des choses que j'entends
confession en confidence mais quel
intérêt de balancer politique
aujourd'hui et de demain
je pense qu'il y a pas de raison que les
choses doivent être dites et que ce qui
fait la force de cette émission c'est
justement qu'on parle de tout à fait
librement tous c'est intéressant dans
une télévision qui est très compassée
qui est très fermé sur elle-même je
trouve intéressant au moins une fois par
semaine le samedi soir de pouvoir tout
dire
je ne crains pas qu'on m'enlève des
monopoles de confidence mais ma question
que je me pose c'est de me dire est-ce
qu'on peut tout dire en public c'est ça
une question je pose au public
d'ailleurs
et pour finir vous défendez la femme car
vous dites j'étais impuissant pendant un
an j'ai donc passif pendant un an et
c'est un sale boulot de se faire mettre
son pouvoir rendre l'appareil donc
finalement vous êtes assez féministe
d'une certaine façon
[Musique]
Guillaume du stand je pense que pour
vous une interview psy serait assez
bienvenue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
interview psy est-ce que vous êtes mytho
j'ai peur que vous soyez tout là j'ai
peur j'ai peur que vous ayez j'ai peur
que vous ayez une croix dans chaque case
allez courage
donc vous êtes mégalo vous le
reconnaissez non j'ai le sens de ma
valeur d'accord est-ce que vous êtes
parano
extrêmement mais je pense que j'ai
vraiment de bonnes raisons de l'être
pourquoi parce que tout le monde m'en
veux
quand je m'en rends compte c'est trop
tard
est-ce que vous êtes maso non vous
n'avez pas souffrir non non je l'ai été
cliniquement mais je suis plus quoi
parce que j'ai beaucoup travaillé c'est
très difficile à soigner est-ce que vous
êtes sado
depuis que je suis plus maso j'ai des
opportunités pour la lettre et j'essaie
de résister je vous montrer si vous êtes
sodo
est-ce que vous êtes Rocco ben non
malheureusement vous êtes gros lolo non
je suis bien refoulé c'est à dire que
depuis qu'il y a le sida comme je trouve
que c'est vraiment trop trop trop lourd
pour moi de coucher avec une femme parce
que c'est risqué
j'ai plus jamais de relation avec des
femmes alors que s'il y avait pas ça je
pense que ça m'arriverait
gros lolo en fait vibro
j'ai plus fait ça depuis des années trio
moi j'aime plutôt 4 et plus
geronto
j'aimerais bien qu'on soit avec moi
est-ce que vous êtes
de Sam mod est-ce que vous êtes travelo
est-ce que vous êtes travelo non et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu